so the people around you're often the
hardest the change especially you're
coming in with high energy like you need
to change your life bubble bubble pop
and even though you want them to be like
way up here they're not ready to take
that jump and if you're pushing them all
the time on it they're gonna just not
want to hear you even though you have
one of their best interests in mind
yeah someone told me they didn't want to
hear my psychobabble right because I was
really positive so you have to meet them
where they're at with compassion and
it's coming from a place of love but
you're not meeting where they're I I
think that really morbidly obese people
are depressed and don't know it and it's
a really hard cycle so if you talk
yourself into going to a gym and people
look at you you won't go back to that
gym yep get emotional but I had to start
my chair get emotional it's great 213
pounds today which a lot of people
wouldn't nice weight you know was so
much better and now I can do some
exercise yeah I couldn't before so I was
and people saying well you're not too
heavy to go to the gym but I really was
I couldn't go there because of the way I
felt I would like to to help people that
are morbidly obese realize that they
have self-worth and that they have the
ability to change their life how to do
that I've been trying with my friends
and that's not working because I it
seems like I'm a pusher you have to meet
people where they are and so the people
around you're often the hardest to
change especially if you're coming in
with high energy like you need to change
your life buh-buh-buh-buh your husband
who came to the workshop who wasn't very
into you know the person development
stuff left halfway through and
supporting you great I didn't meet him
where he was at right it's not that we
can't connect is that I didn't meet him
where he's at yeah that's hard to do in
a workshop when you've got a room full
of pee
right because people are different spots
so if I went at your husband's pace
everybody else would be bored and like
want to go faster but that's okay when
you're meeting people 101 it's meeting
people where they're at and even though
you want them to be like way up here
they're not ready to take that jump and
if you're pushing them all the time on
it they're gonna just not want to hear
you even though you have one of their
best interest in mind so you have to
meet them where they're at with
compassion so imagine the you of when
did you start this journey of like
transformation is great so like you of
five years ago you know you've been
obese your entire life if somebody came
in say hey you need to cut sugar you
need to like lose weight right and you
shut them out yeah you might say you
know in your best moments thank you
thinking of me and in your most worst
moments much worse so now you're you're
being that person it's coming from a
place of love but you not meeting them
where they're at so some people you can
take by their hand and like take giant
leaps across the city and some people
you need to like slowly cross the cross
work with as long as you're moving
forward so that's it's when people go on
a journey of personal development they
always it immediate your family the
people around you it's like I've changed
and what you guys all change to let's go
like you could have a great life when
you come off of some crazy person right
right right quit but it's compassionate
like understand you are the same way
five years ago yeah so so what great
exercises you think about like close
your eyes and put yourself back to five
years ago and didn't think what would I
tell that person how could you get that
person to move and take action it
probably wouldn't be yelling at them and
saying hey you got to do this right
you'd be hugging them and understanding
them and listening to them and yeah and
and you just going off and doing your
thing and seeing the results like people
who haven't seen you in six months I'd
be like
like a lot of energy and moving around
then what happened right and then that
that will inspire questions and they'll
see you doing your thing just by you
doing what you're doing is an
inspiration without you having to say
anything and when people come and talk
to you then it creates a window so I
like I like creating windows for people
I don't push them through here's the
window I'll open up a door right if they
want to walk through we'll go on a
journey together if not it'll be another
door and by you continue to do what
you're doing
you keep getting better you keep you
keep losing weight you keep being more
happy now you've got your trailer you're
traveling across the you know America
it's gonna be inspiration with people
and and some people will then reach out
and say like how did I'm ready I've had
my moment like I'm I had a health scare
how do I fix this
but if they've only seen you as this
person who's like preaching to them
they're not gonna want to trust you with
their feelings where I'm sitting in a
chair okay so you're free to do it so
what do you have to do you got to do it
and you can do it as a as a YouTube
video it's gonna be a longer video
Instagram gives you one minute you could
do one minute clip you could film it
like give me something I can do in one
minute it's the two percent thing right
it's like if you get me doing one minute
of or whatever I'm gonna do in my chair
right but twenty-one minutes for
somebody is it is an eternity for
someone just getting started up right
yes like if if I looked at all his
barber stuff and said you need all of
this to get started if I was an early
condition to like write to look after my
beard I need all that
it's just too much you start with one
thing you start with one thing and then
that 2% momentum builds up so you've
been doing one-minute videos it's 2% of
the way but if I'm if I'm if I'm
watching you just like you said
I cut out sugar because of my husband
and that like created this positive
cascade in my entire life yeah that's
what you need to do one small thing the
2% rule that creates a positive cascade
for people so a 30 second video
one-minute video what can I do every day
from my chair that then I'm I'm building
a positive habit right yeah
nobody's gonna connect in a 21 minute
video every day you're you wouldn't do
that
the 5-year old version of you five years
ago wouldn't do that I mean with 21
minutes every day I'm gonna sit there
and do a work cause there's no way but
there are also moments of you five years
ago where you thought okay maybe I
should do something it may be you know
like I know I don't like my life I don't
like where I'm at I don't know I don't I
don't know what to do and if you saw
this woman who had these one-minute
chair exercises you know you might just
give it a shot for a minute you know
like your husband gave my workshop a
shot for 90 minutes or whatever right
yeah great
right like is momentum but for him that
might be like insanely good right right
for for for for Evan right like doing
doing this it's not gonna do anything
for him right hit in a minute there you
go okay we have branding all over the
place here oh there you go
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
but first
for us like for him doing this isn't
gonna do anything for him right but what
for someone for you five years ago that
would that would have been like a major
milestone just sitting there for a
minute and lifting your arms up and down
right yes right yes so you create that
positive cascade and you do it from
you're always talking about your story
and why it's important and like what
this is the exercise you go back to and
think about the five year five years ago
your version what would you tell
yourself how would you do it everybody
has a different style so like Eric
Thomas will yell at you and like be
excited and rage right I love you to
et's he's amazing Oprah is gonna hug you
right but et nope I say the same thing
their message is almost exactly the same
just the approach and the delivering the
style is totally different right some
people want to be all that some people
wanna be hugged great so what would you
have want it to be how would you move
that person and then think about if I'm
gonna do one minute exercise video
not just the exercise of what's the
messaging around it right it's like I
know you feel like you can ever lose
weight and you may not like yourself but
you know what one minute at a time one
minute a day we're gonna change your
life and make you feel good so let's go
you're sitting in your chair we have a
soup can and we're gonna do curls hidden
right
alright get Instagram but but it's just
a decision to do it you could figure out
that the tech is super easy get
Instagram you downloads the the app you
create your account you set it up put
your phone up against the couch and you
press record and you just go for a
minute right like that part's easy but I
would think about the tone of the
messaging with your especially in
showing your Extro just welcoming people
what you would have liked to hear and
then the encouraging nature of the
entire video and then and then what do I
end with like people will people start
their day with well you see he came in
here as the people I started my day with
your videos so people will start their
day with your one minute thing and how
you leave them from that video will be
important so a positive message that the
version of you five years ago would be
open to hearing right now like go do a
question like we got this and right
pretty soon you'll be 50 pounds lighter
you wouldn't if you wouldn't have heard
that so go back to who you were
now who you are and then have compassion
for that person
[Music]
Oh excited daily 1 minute workout videos
alright there you go he's gonna look for
it if you want to get coached by me
one-on-one to help you build your brain
and make money as a thought leader check
out my next workshop in Toronto the link
is right there next to me continue to
believe and I'll see you there